we've had a bunch of really big consumer
goods companies report their earnings
and it provides some really valuable
insights into what is driving inflation
unilever that's the parent company of
hellmann's mayonnaise and ben and
jerry's ice cream they said that
inflation was the worst since the
financial crisis and
they had this really valuable chart
which looks at how their raw materials
cost essentially have increased or
changed over the past decade now off the
financial crisis they went up but then
we had the best part of 10 years where
it only went up 100 100 or 200 million
euros per year until last year went out
1.3 billion and this year they expected
to go up 3.6 billion euros now you can
look at this chart from bloomberg
intelligence which looks at some of
those underlying raw materials cost
things like petrol energy uh
agricultural goods
are orders of magnitude greater than
they have been at any stage in the past
five years
let's take it to nestle biggest consumer
goods company in the world makes
chocolate plenty more besides
you can see here how demand for their
products increase that means that
actually they need more raw materials
and they can't necessarily get them as
readily so those raw materials they can
get they have to pay more for in turn
then they increase their prices that's
the the
darker green line here in order to
offset those higher goods now that can
be detrimental to your profit margins
but it can help them in two or three
years time because the cost of your
goods will perhaps start to decline even
while the price you're charging your
customers remains relatively steady so
as you come out of this
inflationary crisis it can be really
helpful for those companies
you